bonsoir à tous pour cette 200e émission
de bouillon de culture merci pour votre
fidélité merci beaucoup
en direct un invité exceptionnel tout
simplement parce que son palmarès
d'acteur de cinéma est exceptionnel et
aussi parce que la cinémathèque dans un
mois va lui rendre un hommage mérité en
présentant cinquante deux de ses films
monsieur alain delon
et puis c'est prématuré d'applaudir des
tendances ici sinon c'est aussi une
manière aussi pour la télévision de
rendre hommage à un acteur dont les
films parce que très souvent sur toutes
les chaînes de télévision voilà alors ce
qui n'est pas très connu c'est que la
cinémathèque française à dents et et son
directeur d'alors monsieur henri
langlois vous ont rendu hommage il y a
trente deux ans c'était en 1964 et vous
n'aviez alors que 29 ans et est ce que
quel était le sentiment de d'alain delon
pour l'hommage aussi précoce à 29 ans
que mon avis unique dans l'histoire du
cinéma
je vais vous répondre en une minute si
vous le permettez et si vous le
permettez aussi j'aimerais d'abord vous
dire deux choses la première c'est que
je suis heureux de célébrer cet
événement votre compagnie parce qu'enfin
la 200e de pivot c'est un événement ça
n'est pas n'importe quoi et avec
n'importe qui et bah ouais
la deuxième chose c'est que je voudrais
rassurer d'ores et déjà d'entrer vos
détracteurs vous pourquoi vous imaginez
bien quand même qu'après quelques 750
apostrophe étendre les guillemets 200
plants de culture vous ne vous êtes pas
attiré que des sympathies avec des
amitiés
alors je les entends d'ici pivot
s'écoute parler puis voteront pour cela
jean glycines et j'en passe et des plus
savoureuses
mais j'ai ouï dire que quelque part j'ai
même lu ici ou ailleurs que l'on
s'étonnait que quelqu'un d'aussi érudit
que bernard pivot reçoivent pour sa 200e
saltimbanques
voilà et en face à face en tête à tête
un saltimbanque voir voir un inculte
alors je voudrais les rassurer et leur
dire qu'ils ont raison
effectivement si si mais vous permettez
alors ils ont raison c'est à dire que on
m'a souvent crédité de 2 2 bouillonnant
d'imagination j'étais bouillonnante vie
j'ai même au cours de ma vie de ma
carrière bu quelques bouillons qui cela
donnait pas de culture croyez moi mais
je ne suis pas vraiment ce qu'on appelle
dans le sens de foisonnement un bouillon
de culture alors je m'en excuse mais
vous m'avez invité je suis là et vous
aidez moi et je suis très content de
voir se voir acceptées ou zapper à de
noël
moelleux personne n'osa au contraire
mais c'est un bon début au contraire ils
restent là ils se disent tiens qu'est ce
qu'il va se passer ça va être formidable
pour répondre maintenant alors
maintenant oui devant la cinémathèque en
c1 32 ans javier j'avais 29 ans 64 après
on a le même âge va pas se tromper
je suis votre aîné de cinq mois merci
j'en suis ravi je voudrais pas que ça se
voit mais en face b r écoutez
bon alors la cinémathèque évidemment
henri-langlois m'a fait cet honneur il y
à il y a trente deux ans j'étais le
premier surpris bien sûr alors je
voudrais bête les choses tout de suite
très au clair très au point
je pense que le je n'aime pas le mot
hommage vous savez pompeux je ne me sens
pas si vous voulez je ne me sens pas
concerné par ce mot mais enfin c'est
fait pour ça que je m'expliquais après
sur la carrière lorsque henri langlois
en 1964 rendu cet hommage donc je pense
que c'était beaucoup plus à l'acteur
j'avais fait à l'époque huit ou neuf
films je venais de terminer douze je
vais l'énergie à ma table
d'accord je venais de terminer le
guépard 12 donc et le film de verneuil
mélodie en sous-sol
et puis je me souviens de mémoire comme
ça il a déclaré un des noms qui qui fut
rocco pour visconti sans lequel les
clips suite été différent et qui a su
marquer plein soleil de mémoire c'est un
peu ce qu'il a dit donc c'était beaucoup
plus pour moi un hommage un acteur
aujourd'hui en 1996 la cinémathèque
française avec qui je me suis entretenu
avec son directeur de midi qui me fait
le plaisir d'être ici présents ce soir
et sa collaboratrice
agnès wildenstein j'ai souhaité j'ai
voulu que ce soit si vous voulez un
hommage plus suffisamment votre multi
qui donne le nom à une carrière et pas
ni un acteur né un personnage pourquoi
carriére acteurs sont non c'est pas du
tout la même chose lorsque qu un acteur
ça court ça me concerne moins moi c'est
jouer carrière une carrière qui ont
aggravé vous dire que ça ne se fait pas
tout seul à manon sagement doute revient
alors ça c'était d'ailleurs le catalogue
du dia 30
1964 la cinémathèque alors simplement je
dis les gens d'ici mais pourquoi
maintenant
eh bien il avait fait à ce moment-là
dana dont il a déjà fait rocco et ses
frères guépard de visconti la effet les
clips d'antonioni plein soleil
et quelle joie de vivre de clément et
mélodie en sous-sol d'henri verneuil
évidemment et là je me suis dit si vous
étiez mort à 30 ans à ce moment là mais
votre gloire sera encore plus grande que
celle que vous connaissez aujourd'hui
parce que le jeune acteur foudroyé
s'était il est dressé dans cinq ou six
chef-d'oeuvre c'était formidable
c'est évident indépendamment de son
talent qui était certain c'est ce qui
est arrivé à james dean
oui si jamais il n'était pas mort comme
il est mort en 1955 d'ailleurs on en
parlera sûrement pas encore aujourd'hui
mon avis enfin bref vous êtes d'être
athée peut-être bientôt rompu thaler
homme était quand même
non je voulais expliquer la différence
entre un hommage à un acteur et une
carrière une carrière ça ne se fait pas
seul ça se fait dire d'abord c'est un
concours de circonstance ya souvent un
faisceau de deux moments comme ça je
veux dire le conjoncture et puis ça se
fait aussi avec des metteurs en scène
avec des écrivains avec des auteurs
quelque part aussi avec des acteurs
souvent que ça fait ça peut se faire
aussi par vous même par votre talent
votre intelligence professionnel votre
opiniâtreté votre sur votre volonté mais
ça se fait aussi et surtout et du public
moi je ne connais pas d'acteur si vous
voulez qu'ils aient fait une longue
carrière qui est dur et qui perdurait
sans public
alors le public vous a souhaité tel que
vous le voulez au début il vous a suivi
il vous a précédé des fois ils vous
aiment des fois moins mais c'est lui qui
fait que vous êtes encore là et si je
suis encore là veut dire ce soir c'est
quand même grâce au public et puis à
côté à ce que nous avons fait tous
ensemble dans cette carrière alors juste
pour lancer cette émission un très court
extrait de l'assassinât de trotsky de
joseph losey paris j'aimerais savoir
ce qui se passe derrière ces cieux si
classés
voilà je vais pas savoir ce qu'il y a
derrière o2 yeux je sais pas mais c'est
vrai savoir quand même cette émission
voudrais répondre à cette question au
fond qui est de long et au fond qu'est
ce qu'il ya derrière ces deux yeux bleu
d'acier
on voudrait un petit peu répondre à tout
ça alors voici comment nous allons
procéder
je vais vous proposer un certain nombre
de mots classés par ordre alphabétique
sur lesquels je vous demanderai de
réagir quitte à moi ensuite de vous
relancer avec des questions autrement
dit c'est une sorte d'abécédaire alain
delon de a à z
rassurez vous il y aura des mots des
lettres qu'on va oublier parce qu'on ne
peut pas tout mettre
alors vous avez accepté le principe de
cet entretien je vous en remercie mais
jouera surtout les mots je vous
proposerai ne connaissez pas et ils sont
les mots de votre famille de votre tribu
les de votre profession et de votre
histoire
et puis afin de
nous illustrerons évidemment vos propos
de quelques courts extraits de deux
films que nous avons gardé en mémoire et
laure donc nous allons commencer par
évidemment comme acteur en revenir à 2 à
comme acteur à z comme zorro alors comme
acteur l'usan acteurs c'est un mag
acteurs c'est mon métier j'en suis fier
et j'ai toujours considéré si vous
voulez que je faisais partie d'une
certaine famille et d'une certaine race
j'appellerai la race des acteurs ce qui
fait pas toujours plaisir dans ma façon
de l'exprimer vie damehame à mes
confrères
parce que pour moi c'est très clair je
pense qu'ils étaient un peu le sentiment
de gabin donc je les exprime aussi pour
lui ce soir il y avait les comédiens et
les acteurs sans que ce soit péjoratif
l'un pour l'autre évidemment je
m'explique qu'il a très brièvement parce
que si on a 25 lettres de l'alphabet on
n'est pas sortis on est là demain alors
les comédiens su être comédien c'est une
vocation c'est un métier
alors on apprend ce métier je veux dire
que ce soit au cours simon cours florent
puis après on fait le conservatoire et
puis après en général on se dirige vers
le théâtre et accessoirement on arrive
au cinéma après et on fait du cinéma
acteur c'est c'est presque un accident
c'est des gens qui au début je veux dire
n'était pas fait pour ce métier
véritablement qui ne pensaient peut-être
pas même le faire et puis qui un jour
pour un concours de circonstance ont mis
leur personnalité forte en général au
service de ce métier là c'est le cas de
gamins qui n'était pas un acteur de
formation c'est le cas de gabin qui
était un militaire qui faisait du caf
qu'on sait le cas de ventura découvert
qu'un par gabin qui était lui catcheur
qui venait de se casser qui était plus
beau pour le cas de ceux qui ne savaient
pas quoi faire c'est le cas de burt
lancaster qui vient du cirque qui a
commencé sa carrière à 40 ans c'est le
cas de beaucoup de gens comme cela
donc c'est une race tout à fait à part
et c'est si vous voulez le principal
distinguo entre le comédien et l'acteur
sans que ça ne soit pas du tout les
sujets relatifs vous n'avez aucun
diplôme de comédie le nom de jeu peuvent
jamais fait d'école monde de rink
maintenant vous n'avez pas de ces apps
et de comédiens j'ai pas de s'échapper
de comédiens journée d'autres mais j'ai
pas celui-là pas de quoi on peut foncer
au pcr tous que oui je suis parti juste
après alors et combien de films comme
acteur
au total ça fait combien 80 des
poussières 80 des poussées avec comme
metteur en scène deux alors et est ce
que parce que vous avez joué parfois des
rôles très très fort je pense à roko à
ripley aux samouraïs à monsieur klein
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
c'est ces rôles parfois vous on me ment
dans l'instant vous voulez viviez vous
ont marqués psychologiquement
non je j'ai rarement est pratiquement
jamais été marquée par un rôle
psychologiquement non alors ça veut dire
que si vous aviez fait 80 films qui ne
seraient pas les ce que vous avez fait
vous seriez le même homme je ne serai
pas le même homme parce que par ses 80
films à travers ses 80 films j'ai je
pense avoir vécu 80 vie différente parce
que chaque film est une vie chaque film
est une aventure et chaque film est une
doit vous arrange de rosie absolument
mais papa pan comme vous l'avez entendu
ou laisse à vos tendres ah oui mais
quand même signification atterrir
peut-être même à votre insu de ses films
parfois moi je pense que quand on ça ne
m'a pas profondément et gsm ont changé
je veux dire que vous étiez depuis la
puissante quand vous jouiez rocco qui
était un jeune homme bon est-ce que vous
n'étiez pas plus beau que d'habitude
quand vous avez joué replay qui est
ainsi ni l'autre ne devraient pas venir
parce que sinon que d'habitude en non
parce que c'est le propre de l'acteur
tel que je le conçois moins qu'ils aient
pu dire d'acteurs de fait partie de ma
famille d'acteurs caméléon capable de de
changer comme ça des personnages capable
de s'inscrire dans un personnage
d'entrer dans dans un personnage comme
dans un costume et de vivre les acteurs
la différence entre général élémentaire
entre les comédiens les acteurs c'est
que les comédiens jouent que les acteurs
vivent entre jouer un rôle interprété un
roulé le vivre c'est tout à fait
différent
ce soir par exemple en face de vous je
ne joue pas je vis non non non je suis
pas sur les comédiens seraient tous de
votre vie mais qu'est-ce que quand vous
plonger dans votre mémoire est ce que
vous faites la distinction une
distinction très nette entre le cinéma
et votre vie personnelle votre vie
privée entre la fiction et la réalité ou
est ce que l s'interpénètrent dans notre
mémoire ya toujours une interprète
interpénétration c'est évident à mon
avis beaucoup plus sur les femmes que
chez les hommes pour les femmes que pour
les hommes c'est pour ça que j'ai
déclaré un jour que c'était un métier
très difficile et trop difficile
les femmes mais je veux dire c'est une
question d'équilibré c'est une question
de formation question d'éducation
une question de caractère comme pas eu
d'effet je pense l interpénétration tout
simplement parce que je pense à remich
justement je pensais à romy qu'ils
m'expliquent game haïdar que l on bon
c'est fiction réalité sont mélangés non
pourquoi donc
si parce que fait allusion à quoi vous
avez été ça n'a rien remis par exemple
m'expliquer on y avait de grands et de
profonde détresse comme ça il
m'expliquait que c'était très difficile
quelquefois de quitter le plateau en
étant l'impératrice sissi est de se
retrouver chez soi avec un problème de
gaz de factures et que et le lendemain
route c'est ça qui est rigolo dans la
ville et bien oui s'il n'avait jamais
été l'impératrice sissi de gallagher
alors et puis le lendemain repartir
comme ça et se retrouvait sur un plateau
adulé adoré servi choisir ses il faut il
faut un équilibre très fort en général
alors et c'est pas par hasard que toutes
ces femmes dont on parle et qu'on a
beaucoup aimé sont toutes parties pas
forcément de leur plein gré à la haye ce
que j'ai eu raison de dire a comme amour
ah oui oui parce que l'amour à moitié et
toute ma vie dira l'amour l'amour de nos
métiers d'abord l'amour tout court jus
je me sens quelque part débiteur de
l'amoureux suce moi même un enfant de
l'amour donc ça c'est à ma naissance et
comme enfant de l'amour j'ai senti cette
pénétration émois de l'amour toute ma
vie j'ai besoin j'ai quelqu'un qui ait
eu la chance d'avoir beaucoup était aimé
et j'ai beaucoup aimé moi même et je
veux dire l'amour est une motivation
c'est à dire à la fin de votre vie vous
pourrez dire l'amour a été là avec le
cinéma la grande affaire de ma vie je
pourrais dire ça mais je verrai plus
beau c'est pas moi qui l'écrit c'est
bien dommage je dirais
j'ai souffert souvent je me suis trompé
quelquefois mais j'ai aimé c'est moi qui
ai vécu et non non pas un être factice
créé par mon orgueil et mon ennui c'est
ce que je souhaite un jour avoir sur ma
tombe comme épitaphe c'est d'alfred de
musset la réplique de pernik ans mais ça
mais vous êtes par rapport à nous les
gens ordinaires qui vont
les hommes ordinaires qui devront courir
après les femmes on est aimé de ses
récits messi est ce que vous êtes et ce
que vous sont les femmes qui toute votre
vie vous ont couru et même dans votre
enfance vous ont couru après de ce point
de vue de l'amour vous êtes un
extraterrestre quand même non j'ai
peut-être eu dès le départ plus de
chance que les autres ça n'est pas une
chance qui est qui peut forcément dur et
je veux dire mais c'est pas un grand
événement oui enfin bon ce n'est
l'instant on ne peut pas faire la
différence
si le problème si la comparaison est
l'instant peut pas comparer il vous
manquait rien alors b comme j'ai jamais
été malheureux de ce côté là ah oui ça
je m'en doute bon oui il ya une pointe
de jalousie la bon alors mais comme
beauté je l'avais alors aidé comme
beauté normand va unir la jalousie des
communautés à souvenirs personnels en
1957 j'avais 22 ans vous en aviez aussi
22 ans je vais donc au cinéma voir un
film d'yves allégret qui s'intitule
quand la femme s'en mêle
alors vous n'étiez pas du tout célébré
c'est un peu plus que c'était votre
premier film alors je vois ce film je
dis oh [__] qu'est-ce qui les bourses
se dit alors déjà un peu la jalousie
après les films sont venus gets zepos
vue et lors la mère la soeur les
cousines les petites amies 10 ans a vu
de long et ses sbires
alors qu'est-ce qu'il est beau etc c'est
bon il n'y a pas que moi qui ai du tier
2 quai du je dirais soutenir votre
beauté etc
ç'a dû en faire bisquer plus d'un quand
même non je ne sais pas je vous écoute
mais et/ou des bons je voudrais d'abord
qu'on sache bien que c'est pas de ma
faute
non c'est à ma mère que je dois ça bon
je les ai toujours dit alors bon elle
m'a doté d'un physique disons favorable
bon bah merci bon dieu merci mais qu'est
ce que le super qui se voulait que je
fasse
alors effectivement si vous voulez
professionnellement dans la vie c'est
autre chose professionnellement ça peut
servir un certain temps mais ça ne
suffit pas pour durer ça tu joues pas
pour aller au delà
ce qui m'importe et moi dès mon jeune ma
jeune enfance où je me suis aperçu si
vous voulez que j'avais cette petite
différence qui fait que c'est parce
qu'on appelle l'égalité des chances et
c'est pour ça que je ne comprends rien
n'allait l'été des chances parce qu'au
départ nous ne sommes nous n'avons pas
tous les mêmes chances et dans ce cas la
présence est une chance supplémentaire
c'est un fait c'est vrai et pas
seulement du côté masculin mais aussi du
côté féminin
convenons-en la fille qui vit de vesoul
monte à paris c'est pas la plus laide
bon alors ce qui m'importait à l'époque
si vous voulez ou ma vie était comme ça
assez bousculé assez mouvementée à les
deux collèges en prison de deux collèges
ans en pension fait par lapsus pension à
l'armée et ses terrasses qui m'importait
si vous voulez c'est de ne pas être
synonyme de la chanson de brel bo bobo
et qu'on la fois venir et je crois qu'à
cette époque là j'ai tellement vécu
fortement avec le physique que m'avait
donné la nature
j'en ai oublié d'être con je suis désolé
faudra faire avec alors est ce que est
ce que au fil des années quand on vit
est ce que la beauté ne vient pas un
handicap pour jouer alors curieusement
c'est à ces écuries c'est assez marrant
ce que vous dites moi la beauté a plutôt
été un handicap à mes débuts
ah bon oui ah bon ça a pas l'air si
parce que c'est un autre palmarès
non mais ça n'a rien à voir son palmarès
je veux dire les gens qui me connaissent
les gens qui m'aiment bien et on a
encore quelques uns mais y en a même
beaucoup ici dans cette salle ce soir
vous diront qu'ils me considèrent
puisqu'on parle d'un canon critères de
beauté plus beau aujourd'hui qu'en 1960
alors je ne sais pas pourquoi votre
famille entière pensait vraiment ce
qu'ils avaient d'exceptionnel mais je
vais vous donner la preuve de ce film
qu'elle affine les femmes s'en mêlent je
n'ai gardé aucun souvenir
ouais je me rappelais pas l'histoire
sauf que je me rappelle très bien alors
que ce n'était pas une très bonne et moi
je me rappelle très bien joué le rôle
donc d'un d'un truc tu en sois gardes du
corps et je me rappelais c'est la seule
scène dont je me souvenais c'était une
scène qui se jouait dans une pâtisserie
avec les français françoise sauver yagg
notre documentaliste a retrouvé cette
scène dans la pâtisserie avec sophie
daumier en regard ok on entend la preuve
vous allez voir vous êtes fait religieux
qu'est ce que vous attendez
ça refroidisse un petit moment s'il vous
plaît
thorgal
on va khadir l'échappement libre à paris
vous étiez pas mal écouté on va pas
jouer un jeu parce que je crois que vous
allez perdre
ok donc on va passer la main et on
parlera d'autre chose parce que vous
prenez la salle ici ce soit le témoin et
si vous leur demandez s'il me préfère
physiquement la comparant aux critères
canons de beauté à ce soir je pense
évidemment que la dijon tous de votre
âge m'explique pourquoi vous ramener
tout un c'est pas parce que les élus
n'ont pas votre en fait ce n'est pas ma
y'avait cervelle oui je feuillère
bernard blier tu sais et je crois que ça
mais je crois même c'est la première
scène que vous avez jamais joué au
cinéma c'est la première c'est que c'est
la première scène c'est celle dont je me
souvenais scénique
je voudrais quand même ajouter quelque
chose si je peux c'était une autre
époque c'était en 1957 et c'était un
autre cinéma
c'était l'époque de ce qu'on appelait
les jeunes premiers les jeunes premiers
devaient avoir faim en avoir un physique
favorable à la caméra et s'exprimer de
la sorte je crois pas aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui jouerait comme ça moi je
le fous d'or a bon dos et vous auto est
mauvais on va coûter à la limite
bon je pense alors b comme business b
comme business jean-paul mot business
parce que c'est vrai que votre griffe et
est vendu il ya des producteurs d'olives
sont vendus
dans le monde entier surtout en asie bon
vous êtes devenu un homme d'affaires
simplement pour votre argent
pas pour gagner de l'argent ce plan si
vous dites business justement aussi dans
dans le le côté business man homme
d'affaires je ne suis pas du tout à le
faire suis un homme d'idées je suis un
homme de conception je suis un homme de
plein de choses mais je ne suis pas un
homme d'affaires dans le sens même de
businessman l'homme d'affaires jean
n'est pas ni la formation ni le temps ni
l'envié ni le courage et ça ne me plaît
pas vous avez mais par contre j'ai des
gens j'ai des gens qui sont je veux dire
je délègue j'ai des gens qui sont eux
les hommes d'affaires j'ai des gens ils
sont les avocats d'affaires j'ai des
gens qui sont des démarcheurs d'affaires
et qui font ces choses là qu'ils ont de
quoi des parfums pourtant votre nom des
onze jeux ça n'a rien à voir ça c'est
donc dans tous les pays dans le monde
entier d'ailleurs relativement sauf en
france puisque nul n'est prophète dans
son pays j'ai une différentes marques
comme ça que je fabrique sous licence en
chine aussi et parce que j'ai japon ça
se vend 2 était très oui certaines
choses où il est il vrai que des
cigarettes alain delon ouais il ya des
cigarettes alain delon et si vous en
avez un paquet d'accords des cigarettes
n 2 l'an alors bon c'est évidemment
comme cinéma ça me paraît normal
est ce que pour vous le cinéma est un
art aussi importante la peinture n'a pas
du tout pas du tout c'est le septième
d'abord c'est pas ça n'a aucun aucun
rapport à voir ni avec la peinture c'est
un art pour moi c'est un art populaire
mais sais-tu sur un art populaire tout à
fait et c'est surtout un art si vous
voulez à mon avis au niveau des auteurs
et au niveau des réalisateurs des grands
metteurs en scène dont je vous parlerai
tout à l'heure après une faute de rées m
comme et oran c'est une forme de
spectacle
d'accord mais est-ce que d'après vous on
a raison de faire la distinction entre
cinéma d'art et d'essai cinéma populaire
c'est-à-dire d'opposer les clips sa
zorro des clips de d'opposer je sais pas
monsieur klein à trois hommes trois
hommes à abattre et ses devoirs il ya
plusieurs formes de cinéma comme ça
comme il ya plusieurs formes de publier
quand on essaie de contenter ou
d'approcher tout nous il faut faire des
cinémas différence est vrai que monsieur
klein n'a pas forcément la même écoute
que zorro que et que plein soleil n'a
pas la même écoute que pour la peau d'un
flic c'est vrai mais il faut un petit
peu faire tout et c'est justement ce que
moi je me suis attaché à faire tout au
long de ma carrière
ce qui est très difficile et très
délicat derrière d'essayer de toucher et
d'approchés tous les publics il n'y a
pas un public c'est pas vrai il n'y a
pas d'unanimité dans le choix d'un film
à quai et du cinéma vont publier leurs
sa 100ème numéro avec martin scorsese en
couverture et c'est martin scorsese qui
a dirigé est-ce que vous avez souvent
donné des interviews aux cahiers du
cinéma
un seul dans ma vie à sa seule interview
soit sortira de courant - numéros
suivants numéro ça sera votre premier
top-10 donc c'est là où on vient quand
même là un ado moi je vais essayer de
réconcilier le cinéma d'art et d'essai
avec le cinéma populaire vous proposant
une vraie scène de cinéma populaire est
une scène de baiser à monica vitti dans
un film d'art et d'essai il yal éclipse
de d'antonioni
vous rappeler votre premier baiser au
cinéma est avec sophie daumier donc on
va me semblait bien sûr est-ce que vous
rappeler votre premier baiser dans votre
vie privée
oui c'était c'était à ma première
communion à fresnes oui j'ose de
première communion
la journée première communion j'étais
persuadé avoir fait un pêché mortel oui
il m'a fallu dix ans pour m ah oui
beaucoup
alors c'est je vous propose c'est comme
conneries je veux dire par la connerie
parce que quels sont les conneries
d'aujourd'hui qui lui qui nous indigne
il suffit de votre indignation on va
écouter alors des quand on parle de deux
conneries je peux je pense toujours ce
n'a rien à voir avec général de gaulle
dit sa phrase quand il a vu à la
libération de paris sur le char de
drones mort aux cons vaste programme
alors effectivement s'est marié pour
être beaucoup plus d'actualité j'ai un
ami qui me disaient quelques jours aux
médias tu vois dans le fond par cette
période de crise c'est pas le pognon qui
manque c'est pour les cons qui manque
c'est le cash
alors ça c'est une autre forme de cône
et moi je crois que la connerie au xxème
siècle si vous voulez c'est avant tout
la connerie des hommes c'est la connerie
des hommes qui sont incapables de 2,2 de
faire une union entre eux entre nous
c'est la connerie qui engendre les
guerres c'est la connerie qui engendre
le génocide c'est la connaissez celle
des oui cela dit vous êtes quand même
engagé à 17 ou 18 ans on est pour la
guerre d'indochine que vous êtes pas dit
que c'était pas une connerie donc c'est
intéressant sur un plan personnel mais à
l'époque je sais pas vraiment très bien
ce que je faisais mais je les fais de
plein gré et totalement comme je le
souhaitais mais est-ce que sinon des
conneries vous avez commis des grosses
bêtises
après je peu après à part votre jeunesse
dans les communes pas mal de bêtises
mais quand vous êtes devenu un grand
acteur
est-ce que je vais continuer de faire
des bêtises vous voulez personnel
professionnel sait pas prévoir pas
tellement était arrivé comme ça mais je
me vois tout le monde dans son parcours
fait plus ou moins les conneries alors
des comme durerait si vous permettez pas
juste faire une parenthèse pour c je
voudrais vous dire simplement dit gandhi
second voudrais dire c'est comme
chomette
c'était un grand acteur et voit
admirable j'ai fait quelques petits
parcours comme ça avec lui tout au long
de ma vie je n'ai jamais regretté
il a donné sa vie pour le théâtre et
toute sa vie et il nous a quittés il ya
deux jours dernièrement la dernière fois
que j'ai vu c'était pour le 25e
anniversaire de la mort du général de
gaulle j'ai eu la chance de l'irak
du général avec lui-même il nous a
quittés il ya trois jours
françois et déjà il nous manque merci
pour lui de faire une parenthèse isolée
alors des comme due aux idées comme duo
d'acteurs et alors c'est vrai que des
duos avec simone signoret avec la
bagarre avec ventura pas vous avez plein
plein lancaster bientôt mais je vous
pose la question parce que j'ai retourné
cette définition de groucho marx groucho
marx disait définition du film de guerre
film de guerre sous le gros show marque
égale rencontre sur le plateau de deux
stars rival pour que c'est une
définition mais c'est là sur l'affairé
beaucoup de demandes non non ce n'est
pas ça drôle non non film de guerre
égale rencontre sur le plateau de deux
stars rival ça vous fait pas rire ou non
mais moi ça me fait beaucoup rire 10 ans
a différé c'est bizarre moi j'ai ouïe
non alors écoutez le cinéma est plein
d'histoires ou des cas deux stars qui
sont vives ont joué au plateau c'est la
guerre et ses films américains on est
plein d'histoires comme ça je sais pas
mais c'est pas vrai ça s'est arrêté
comme en mai donc plein de guerre entre
eux vous voulez oui bien sûr mais son
arrivée à la maison pas plus contre les
couples pas plus contre les enfants nés
par mais pas du tout c'est pas vrai le
saint-siège est plus simple que celle
éditée
et cahiers du cinéma et l'institut dû me
annoncés avec le site publie les
mémoires de gréville essais il est
intitulé 35 ans dans la jungle du cinéma
35 ans d'âge est du cinéma
donc c'est quand même une jungle ben non
alors expliquez moi comment on peut
rester 35 ans dans une jungle vont
sortir avis qu on est à lyon mais non
mais pas forcément parce qu'on aime ça
parce qu'on se sent bien parce qu'on n'a
pas trouvé d'autre excédant la jeune
compris dans cette jungle là qu'on
préfère évoluer qu'on préfère vivre
sinon on ne reste pas 35 ans dans une
jungle
mais c'est vrai qu'on vous a souvent
opposé par exemple jean paul belmondo et
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai ça c'est
des trucs de journalistes des trucs de
médias c'est pour faire vendre du papier
enfin c'est pas c'est pas nouveau ça
existe tous les jours à propos de
n'importe qui c'est pas vrai je n'ai
jamais été il ya jamais eu de guerre sud
mais il n'y a jamais eu de guerre sur
les plateaux c'est pas pour ça qu'on
fait du cinéma il ya eu des mésententes
ya eu des disputes quelquefois il ya
même plus fort que l'autre mais il n'y a
jamais eu de guerre avec un autre
quiconque pense qu'il me concerne les
paons ce qui concerne celui que vous
avez cité jean paul benoît et moi pas du
tout c'est alors et figure qu'on a
retrouvé la première scène oui
belmondo vous êtes ensemble c'était dans
en 1907 et toi c'était soit belle et
even deuxième film et de l'autre
allégresse et démarre avec allégresse
pire aux algues assez fort et n'a fait
mais je ne suis pas très seul j première
ma copine on apprend créé avec nous la
fait tout le travail
mike grier bon mais pas un mot sur
business on vient vous chercher en
scooter
mais pas question on va sur le tapis
cette les croisements par les flics trop
utile une chignole m'étais pas un peu
d'argent n'est pas madame va circuler en
ville noire pour étouffer la traction à
raphaël pour une tour ou deux afin de
nous doit bien ça non correct bougez pas
je traverse le mur du çon jarry a tout
de suite voilà ouidah quand même de jeu
des acteurs qui ont fait leur chemin
depuis un débat dans une petite scène
oui mais vous vous êtes déjà plus la
vedette que je sais pas si j non mais
j'ai regardé ma fille je pensais bien je
suis incollable jeudi
bon alors autre duo alors dû au très
très émouvant je demande vraiment de
regarder c'est avec simone signoret
votre duo dans l'aveu couderc de pierre
granier-deferre c'est quoi avec mickey
je devais de médecins comme l'état
parce que je sors du bagne
quand premier
mais de quelqu'un
j'étais très jeune
maintenant vous les prédateurs non je
veux plus rien je veux du soleil du vin
c'est bon là
tu as toujours été un grand bonheur de
donner la réplique à simone soit arrivé
beaucoup d eau dans les granges brûlées
c'est un personnage exceptionnel est
magnifique je voudrais signaler que le
vus pp qui dort derrière c'est joris y
est très important jean tissier alors
les duos quand même voudrais vous dire
une chose il ya les duo d'acteurs ça
c'est un duo d'acteurs mais ce qui est
beaucoup plus important je vous le dis
très en passant c'est que dans ma
carrière le vrai duo keita duo qui
dépasse le duo d'acteurs qui était un
idiot de vie de carrière c'est belmondo
et moi même parce que ça fait 40 ans à
dire concourent ensemble et on ne court
pas le 100 mètres tout seul et je suis
sûr que sans jean paul sans moi jean
paul n'aurait pas fait la même carrière
et vice versa c'est absolument évident
et ça fait pratiquement d'une émulation
il ya une concurrence mais parce que
depuis maintenant c'est un c'est un
marathon qu on a couru ensemble 40 ans
42 km presque 1 km par an et on sait au
cours de notre carrière au cours de
notre vie je veux dire indépendamment de
borsalino on sait dépasser une fois
l'autre est en retrait puis on faire
passer puis on s'est fait un croc en
jambe et puis on s'est jeté un coup de
coude et c est finalement au bout du
marathon qui va gagner à votre avion 42e
kilomètre le marathon moi je suis sûr
qu'on va le passer la ligne tous les
deux mains dans la mains ensemble
aujourd'hui ça qui est beau parce que ça
c'est une vie jean paul et moi
impression vous avez une petite tête à
queue de sur lui la cause de cette
émission une petite quoi une petite tête
d'avancé à cause de cette émission comme
je l'attendrai on passera par mme
dalibard
alors comme échec est ce que vous avez
ressenti durement des échecs comme
commerciaux j'entends comme par exemple
monsieur klein de lezay ou bien le
professeur wu est ce que ça ça serait
beaucoup et alors pas au niveau du
spectateur au niveau de l'échec
commercial de vous expliquer pourquoi
parce que bon c'est d'aider des films
dans laquelle j'ai beaucoup mieux je me
suis beaucoup investi en dehors de la
côte et commerciales comme monsieur
klein par exemple parce que ce qu'il
fallait comprendre et expliquer aux gens
à cette époque on ne faisait pas des
films avec des allumettes et que ça
coûtait cher de faire des films et que
quand dans l'optique de tout à l'heure
je vous disais dans l'optique de
rejoindre tous les publics de toucher
tous les publics
on faisait monsieur klein je faisais
monsieur klein après prends ton revolver
ou quoi je faisais le professeur après
euros je faisais j'ai essayé
et en général je faisais des films
commerciaux pour me permettre de
financer des films comme monsieur klein
parce que monsieur klein n'existait
n'existait qu'à cause de moi vous le
savez d'ailleurs et que lorsque le
public ne répondait pas à ses attentes
et qu'ils nous frustré d'une part et qui
en plus il nous faisait faire un échec
commercial c'était dur de repartir et de
relancer la machine après gournay mais
est ce que est ce qu'un échec est aussi
durement ressentie par un acteur ou
simplement donc acteurs de long non ça
me motive houleux où le réalisateur et
le producteur en plus il ya du fric là
c'était le producteur non mais j'étais
moi producteurs c'est tout à fait
différent j'étais producteur et acteur
non moi j'ai enfin le jeu sans aucune
prétention j'ai pas beaucoup d'acteurs
eu d'échec dans ma carrière par rapport
aux 80 films que j'ai fait j'en ai eu
trois ou quatre si vous voulez mais je
les assume totalement
bon donc mais en général ça me motivait
ce genre d'échec parce que moi j'aime
bien mais où là c'était difficile
c'était dans des films comme ceux que
vous avez cités parce qu'ils étaient
faits pour permettre je veux dire avec
l'argent des autres
et si large en europe n'est plus on
pouvait plus faire les autres alors je
voudrais vous proposer eux comme oh mais
avant aux comores comme la mer mais
d'abord deux extraits de films alors
qu'hier on a refait les échecs qui sont
des triomphes
c'est d'ailleurs la piscine de jacques
deray et plein soleil de rené clément et
on va vous voir vous le mauvais garçon
régler son compte les dents les deux
fois moins que celles antérieures à
maurice ronet
[Applaudissements]
même si vous arriviez à contrefaire la
signature vous ne pourriez jamais
reproduire tout une lettre mais si j'ai
votre machine
rien n'est plus facile que d'identifier
les caractères et si je la projet ah ah
c'est pas très gentil ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais en vérité c'est vous qui devriez
jouer le rôle de rooney et c'est celui
que j'ai joué des tours à la wii la
voyez quand je regarde ça trouve ça
admirable et c'est là où comme je
rejoins ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure je veux dire je suis un élément
moi là dedans quand vous voyez cette
scène mise en scène par clément
prodigieuse fabuleuse l'acteur est un
élément donc c'est un élément du film
qui est un élément de ma carrière une
carrière ne se fait pas seul j'en avais
la preuve ici direction soit 700
soutenable dans le film d'audrey aussi
oui d'accord mais c'est vous quand on
vous avait proposé le scénario aurait pu
tomber d'accord mais vous avez très bien
et clément se tromper et vous avez dit
que les non moi je jouais le rôle de
replay c'est ça mon rôle et il n'était
pas d'accord et c'est vous qui l'avait
convaincu puisque vous insistez je vous
le raconter oui effectivement clément
s'était trompé les producteurs aussi
j'étais casté pour l'autre voilà et puis
comme j'étais un jeune débutant un jour
il ya une réunion et clément et les
producteurs et j'ai laissé parler bon
tempérament ma personnalité et j'ai dit
mais si vous vous êtes tous en train de
secours et c'est pas ça pour moi parce
que moi c'est comme ça lui c'est comme
ça et je ne peux pas vous pouvez pas
faire vous êtes en train de faire une
connerie je me suis fait insulter comme
je vous dirai pas les mots par les
producteurs et robert et - hakim pour
qui j'avais la plus grande admiration
rené clément était pâle dans un coin le
film est terminé et d'un seul coup au
fond de la salle il y avait celle qui
était tout pour rené clément qui était
la tête
et dieu sait qu elle était brillante
bella clément et on a entendu rennais
chéri le p tit a raison et tout s'est
arrêté là et le film est ce qu'il est
donc comme quoi aussi l'acteur était
alors le lot semble vous réussir quand
même blague voilà de l'eau vous êtes le
maire de bello je déteste la mer je
déteste l'eau à bon je suis malade comme
un chien au maire et voilà alors je me
souviens très bien du tournage de plein
soleil ça a été épique le soir je
rentrais j'étais dans un état je ne vous
dis pas normalement tourner les scènes
comme ça on attendait que je sois mieux
en mieux si alain c'est quand tu veux
c'est prêt je les tournées bon le dos
reis est tout à fait différente une
piscine quand même pas dans une piscine
mais à cause de plein soleil je me suis
juré de ne plus jamais faire un film sur
la mer et c'est à cause de cela que j'ai
refusé le crabe tambour de shon de
refaire quand on m'a dit deux mois en
mer du nord j'ai dix ans - s'il vous
plaît merci mais c'est le crabe tambour
et a bien sûr mais je ne regrette pas ne
pas y avoir été parce que souffrir à ce
point là est bon e comme égaux aux geo
j'avais compris si vous faites allusion
au culte de soi c'est ça je pense que ça
fait partie je veux dire de la panoplie
des comédiens et des acteurs je ne me
sens pas vraiment viser si ce que vous
pensez je crois qu'il ya beaucoup je ne
suis pas quelqu'un qui a le culte du moi
et je crois que dans dans la profession
il ya des de mes confrères beaucoup plus
en avance que moi sur ce sujet hugo plus
volumineux sur mes joues à libération ce
matin qui présentait l'émission d'idées
disait il évoquera donc alain delon à la
troisième personne s'il se montre à la
hauteur de sa légende
ça c'est des conneries ça vous l'avez
écrit vous même dans un article en 1964
je dirais plusieurs cases casque est bon
et je parlais lorsque j'étais producteur
et metteur en scène je parlais de
l'acteur de l'ong j'avais engagé jeudi
on va demander à don de faire sa pile le
fera bien des gens des essais partie
évidemment s'était tourné en dérision en
ridicule et maintenant ça permet d'une
certaine façon et dans un certain
domaine aux guignols d'exister un petit
peu avec moi puis c'est très bien je
suis chez eux je fais partie de leur
panoplie c'est très bien mais ça c'est
les choses alors c'est vrai bric à
thurso de l'évoquer c'est vrai que en
1964 et non 32 ans j'étais
et une journaliste au figaro littéraire
j'avais été vouloir sur un studio de
saint moritz
vous vous tourniez l'insoumis d'un
cavalier et c'est vrai que j'avais suivi
donc je n'avais bavarder pendant
quelques heures et je vais insister une
scène extraordinaire c'est à dire que
quand vous curieux vous avez tué
flinguer le pauvre jean gérer les raies
et puis après il y avait une scène où
vous traversiez lui une vitre avec vos
mains et c'était une vraie vitre il se
fait oublier d'en mettre une fausse et
vous êtes coupé les doigts
et alors le sang a giclé on était tous
les talents et vous avez été transporté
à l'hôpital on vous a fait des 1000
points de suture et là le témoignage
c'est que vous n'avez aucune plainte
n'est pas gueuler vous avez rien fait
rien du tout ça nous avait pas vraiment
très très bien je vais raconter dans
deux articles j'ai repéré mon chef
bernard pivot j'étais déjà un samouraï
déjà et sammour alors est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de légendes
gg parmi elles comme les gens mais ce
qui est beaucoup de légendes qui vous
agace sur vous il y en a quand même
justement ce clip les gaules mais non il
n'y a pas beaucoup non non je m'en fous
un peu
photo non ce qui compte c'est ce que je
pense moi et surtout les êtres qui me
sont chers et que j'aime et que son
proche voisin quand une réputation comme
est d être un provocateur dans mes
romans provocateur oui non quoi en paix
si quand même dénoncé mais je ne suis
pas un provocateur moi du tout bon j'en
vois je sors pas en minijupe ou
provocateur dans quel sens non je parle
provocation justement donnant pas du
tout en général d'angers
en général je réponds quand on me parle
ou quand un matin qui aimait ses plus
beaux spas ou la provocation chaleur je
suis provoqué j'étais provoqué tout au
long de ma vie de ma carrière et je me
suis toujours défendu et c'est peut-être
ça qu'on me reproche alors j'ai je
voulais vous faire choisir de g comme de
gaulle ou gabin jeudi matin qui
choisissent l'un ou l'autre
moi je sais pour gentil alors c'est pas
gentil ça me rappelle un petit jeu qui
affectionnait particulièrement visconti
châssis connaissait le jeu de la tour
alors il aimait ça ça finissait toujours
débrouillé incroyable parce que
brouillet tout le monde avec tout le
monde
il disait et voilà on joue au jeu de la
tour alors je suis là entre moi et intel
qui tu jettes c'est toujours l'autre
et puis arrivé un moment où dire écoute
là je suis désolé loukil objets vous
chez vous alors là ça finissait dans la
débandade
c'était une espèce de trésor très
scorpio nesc et très viscontien de jouer
à ce jeux mais ils voulaient jour est le
plus aimé alors moi entre de gaulle et
il ya ben je n'ai pas à choisir je les
choisis tous les deux parce que c'est
d'abord de deux des hommes que j'ai le
plus admiré à des des raisons
différentes et aimer au cours de ma vie
et admirer dans mon existence et ces
deux hommes que je respecte infiniment
est bon parce qu'on peut dire c'est déjà
choisir comme père entre de gaulle gabin
et visconti le cadeau rivaux choisit
donc sur ce point un jeu auquel je me
livre alors dépeint j'ai bon alors elle
comme lecture puisque est-ce que vous
livrer ce qu est ce que vous lisez
je lis peu j'ai toujours essayé je lis
peu je dois le dire le jeudi peu et
j'essaie de lire bien alors je ne sais
pas si j'y arrive mais du mois je me à
vertus et vous savez tout au long de ma
vie et de ma carrière j'ai surtout lu
pour le cinéma était à venir pour le
cinéma
alors j'ai lu des scénarios bien sûr on
va gagner et j'ai lu aussi quelques
livres intéressants qu'on me proposait
pour le cinéma qui se sont fait qu'ils
ne se sont pas fait mais j'ai quelques
lectures sel ou moins saine qui va
regarder qu'elle concerne
personnellement les mots d eau provient
par exemple la première fois que j'ai lu
je vous donnerai quelques anecdotes
vous avez dit elle comme vous avez dit
elle comme livre j'aurais pu vous dire
très bien alors london je parle en tant
qu'etat un auteur qui sélectionne tout à
fait particulièrement
j'aime ses romans autobiographiques et
je vous raconter une anecdote ce qui
concerne martin iden par exemple qui est
un film que je devais faire qui n'a
jamais pu se faire qui n'a jamais été
fait autre que la télévision est à peu
près 30 ans une dame à porte dans une
édition très ancienne
un livre et me dit d'un petit mas
fonctionner qui m'aimait beaucoup je
crois me dis tiens ça il faut que tu lis
c'est pour toi il faut que tu le fasses
c'était edith piaf
j'ai lu martin eden et je me suis battue
pendant des années pour certains qui dit
d'elle ça n'a jamais pu faire de la même
façon je vous dirais par exemple je vous
parle des films qui ne sont pas faits
drieu la rochelle l'homme à cheval
c'était un des grands souhaits de faire
le match ça n'a jamais pu se faire
je vous dirai ça vous le savez très bien
par rapport par exemple celle élu deux
fois la recherche du temps perdu
visconti là c'est la dent lozes il a
cassé les dents et finalement on a fait
dira un membre de swann de schlöndorff
qui est simplement un épisode de la
recherche du temps perdu et qui n'est
pas du tout l'oeuvre complète que
voulait faire j'ai d'ailleurs admirable
dans personnage de charles c'est gentil
de venir je ne contredirai pas et aux
médias nous non mais moi je parle
franchement j'ai l'impression que celle
dont on a regardé des films dont on a
regardé beaucoup de vos films ou les
mêmes les mauvais on a vu des mauvais il
y en a quelques-uns mais des nanars
stimulant bon et bien même là vous êtes
pro ces nanars c'est assez amusant ce
que vous n'avez mais nous n'avons pas
d'accord dépit des beaux arts
alors puisqu'on a eu lecture b elle
comme bernard henri lévy ouais mais
attendez c'est parfois les beats un peu
plus vite parce que non mais il fallait
pas faire les lettres de l'alphabet il
est vivant je voulais vous dire quand
même que j'avais un verger un auteur que
ça s'écrit aussi qu'est jean giono qui
souhaitait qu'il voulait que je sois que
je sois angelo angelo qui ne voyait pas
d'autre husser que moi c'était à
l'époque ya longtemps et qui voulait
faire le hussard sur le toit suivi
d'angelo pisias de voulu vous le savez
bon j'aime gens je veux dire soir
guimbeau mieux nous le whizzer c'est
tout ce que j'aime et j'ai un auteur que
j'affectionne tout à fait
particulièrement ils ont repassé à bhl
si vous le voulez dans lequel je me sens
je me reconnais qui est permanent est-ce
bon et je veux dire il est de bon ton il
de si vous voulez il est d'un petit peu
aujourd'hui de de s'épancher sur coelho
est sûre l'alchimiste que je trouve que
l'avait remarquable je les lui moi même
mais je conseillerais à ceux qui ont lu
la chimiste de lire ou de relire par
exemple siddharta d'hermann hesse et je
vous approuve parfaite merci à vous
chers donc vous allez tourner le film la
première fiction de bien arrivé bill ou
mexique
vous êtes j'ai bien compris un
personnage à la fois romain gary
hemingway tout ça oui enfin
bhl bernard henri lévy bhl c'est plus
court et plus facile à quelque part si
vous voulez écrit ce scénario en
collaboration avec jean paul eindhoven
et il en a fait la souhaitait en faire
voulu en faire je crois qu'il a réussi
une forme une sorte d'hommage a mis à
hemingway et à rome a gagné 2,02 et
qu'ils sont suicidés 1
bah oui d'accord l'un et l'autre il y en
a d'autres
peut-être quelques l écrivain suisse
veut dire en général malheureusement
vous avez vu comme c'est toujours les
plus grands qui se suicident c'est pas
les plus mauvais enfin donc bernard
henri lévy a souhaité faire cela et il a
écrit un scénario dont ce sens et c'est
l'histoire que je ne vous raconterai pas
mais brièvement
un écrivain fatigue est là c'est des
soirées parisiennes des prix etc et qui
se retire au mexique à bout de course à
bout de souffle à bout d'écriture et qui
va retrouver là-bas une espèce de formol
est-ce que celui-ci de questions un peu
grave donc ce que ces deux écrivains qui
me font penser
est ce que si votre vie devenait très
difficile si vous étiez très éprouvé
physiquement est ce que c'est une
solution vous envisageriez non seulement
je l'envisagerait mais je suis persuadée
de finir comme ça je pense que je le
ferai ces voix là je vous le dit tout de
go ou et oui le jour où j'aurai
conscience et je prendrai conscience de
ce que je veux de ce que je sais de ce
que je pense je m'en irais je préfère
quitter la table comme dit aznavour
avant qu'elles soient desservies par ce
que je d'abord une espèce de respect que
j'ai vis-à-vis de 2,2 ce public qui me
quitte avec moi depuis 40 ans qui m'a
suivi qui a une certaine image de moi et
puis j'ai moi même si vous voulez une
certaine image que moi c'est un discours
que c'est clairement pas du tout que je
t'ai ne tenait plus facilement avant que
je sois que j'ai deux enfants maintenant
je crois que je retarderait l'échéance
mais si un jour je veux dire ce que je
considère de pire la maladie l'impotence
je crois que j'aurai le courage m
le metteur en scène quels sont vos
grands metteurs en scène ça va les
connaissez les connais rien qu'à leur
époque bien distinctes de ma vie il ya
eu la période visconti la béate clément
la période melville a péri de l'osé
voilà ce qui n'empêche pas que j'ai
aussi travaillé dieu merci avec des gens
aussi talentueux que que bertrand blier
que j'ai fait dix films avec jacques
deray 4 avec henri verneuil je veux dire
il ya un grand 4 grande époque de ma vie
qui ont sont les quatre noms que je vous
ai cités alors voici des extraits de
trois films magnifiques et qui sont
signés donc successivement visconti
melville et bertrand blier
mais voilà
tron un désert et tout à coup un concert
de piaillements désespérés se fait
entendre au fond du couloir
c'étaient les religieuses qui s'étaient
réfugiés dans la chapelle toutes
agglutinées contre l'hôtel dieu sait ce
que l'on redoutait de cette dizaine de
garçons surexcités qui sentait la poudre
et la sphère si vous les aviez vu les
pauvres vieille élèves comme elles
étaient dans leurs robes noires les yeux
exorbités déjà toute prête à recevoir le
le martyre elle japet comme des petits
chiens
tasso ni leurs cris rien à faire mes
soeurs nous n'avons pas le temps nous
reviendrons
quand vous pourrez nous procurer des
novices
[Musique]
où
m
[Musique]
non
j'avais des années que j'ai envie de
parler j'ai l'intention de parler
pendant des heures
cette affaire que je m'emmerde du temps
viendra jamais autant je me suis emmerdé
maintenant je m'amuse et toi aussi tu
vas t'amuser parce que j'en ai peut-être
pas l'air mais je suis un mec vachement
marrant je fais pas rigoler tout le
monde mais toi je vais te fait rigoler
la scène se passe dans une chambre
d'hôtel terminus j'adore et charlotte
elle termine d'ailleurs
non vraiment pourquoi on se fait chier
avoir des triplex et des résidences
secondaires alors qu'on est si bien dans
une chambre terminus tiens si c'était à
refaire je voudrais pas dit si je
reviendrais passer les trains parce que
moi aussi j'aime ça les trains quand je
pense que j'ai passé ma vie à m'occuper
de bagnols et que la seule chose que
j'aime je viens de découvrir ces trains
d'un moyen de transport propice à
l'imagination c'est pas dangereux
et en plus on y fait des rencontres il
ya même certains compartiments lombez
dira dans les battles aussi dans les
ascenseurs dans les portes cochères
aurait ce parti dans les lits mais tu
perds mais je savais que mon histoire
est magnifique ça c'est blier jeudi à
ces billets avancé visconti avant ce
n'est pas car vous avez des reçus à
césar césar vous étiez d'ailleurs pas
dans la salle quand vous avez ces
derniers pas mal ça depuis l'année
dernière des président et les césars
demain vous allez allez aussi pour
rendre hommage à fait du fait un bien
énorme à prendre le relais alors je
rappelle aux ja vo comme ours mais il
faut aller un peu vite
vous êtes le seul français a obtenu un
ours d'honneur au festival de berlin et
janvier ap ap alors j'avais fumé paix qu
en politique mais alors le prenez pas
mal
franchement vous idées politiques je
m'en fous sa longueur ils ont donc
l'impression parce que moi je préfère
je connais pas les autres les vôtres
mais peut-être que je m'en foutrais
aussi dense et elle moi n'ont aucune
importance
bah ouais important non parce que
l'anecdote il est fait pour nous faire
rêver non pas pour nous replonger dans
le dans le microcosme lavelli c'est
dommage qu'on était qu'on ne connaît pas
le temps c'est ça le cinéma c'est le
rêve et on a tué le rêve on est en train
de le tuer attendu quotidien faisant du
misérabilisme
oui cinéma c'était fait pour regarder
les choses et des êtres qu'on ne serait
jamais on est et ça on a tué le rêve
continue
merci bien c'est à vous alors paix que
me passionne alors la paix comme passion
parce qu'on va parler de vos vues
différentes passions là où on n'aura pas
le temps de brosser oui mais vous savez
ma vraie passion quand même la vraie
passion c'est mon métier
oui c'est l'effet de mes 30 ans à la
première nation en dehors de ma vie
privée
le reste d'aucuns diront que c'est
décoder des ddd violon d'ingres ou d un
côté mais je veux dire ma vraie passion
c'est ça mais parions que vous avez eu
des patios les chevaux ou et des basses
que je suis un être passionné par ce que
je suis honnête enthousiasme parce que
je suis un être qui m'émerveille parce
que j'ai peur de l'habitude parce que
j'ai peur de l'ennui et en étant
perfectionniste en plus en étant ou que
vous voyez comme c'est pas simple c'est
pas ça veut dire être ainsi de vivre
avec vous mais je ne vous le fais pas
dire
et bon mais je veux dire c'est parfois
aussi captivant geste autre chose mais
je veux dire donc je suis un être de
passion et toute ma vie est faite de
passion je dirai quand je vous disais je
suis quelqu'un qui m'émerveille parce
que je veux dire toutes les choses
simples mais merveille je suis
émerveillé par les conneries par un fax
par un téléphone sans fil par appelée
new york
ça c'est un peu facile sa merveille tout
ça c'est des choses tout à fait simple
feuillet ac je vais vous les citez une
très belle phrase que j'avais depuis mon
enfance qui me fascine et qui que je
trouve admirable picasso était un génie
vous le savez bon puisqu'on approche là
on aborde la peinture disait le matin
lorsque dans ma baignoire je m'aperçois
que je ne font pas comme une savonnette
déjà je m'émerveille ça super
alors évidemment on va parler de la fin
sur wii et bien où je vais amener c'est
la peinture
mais avant quand même la boxe alors la
boxe a été aussi une de vos passions une
deux passions puisque c'est le même qui
avait organisé et d'une manière
extraordinaire le championnat du monde
entre entre carlos monzon est bien là
vous fait pas les jean claude bouttier
jean claude bouttier pas non mais alors
ça c'est aussi différent je veux dire
c'est pas la boxe il m'a passionné j'ai
toujours aimé la boxe en tant que
spectateur plus content que pratiquant
j'ai quand même plus vu que pratiquée
mais là c'est tout à fait le problème
des différences étaient les stars
il y avait une star une star fabuleuse
qui s'appelait monzon est une chance
française qui s'appelait bouthier
personne ne voulait en arriver à
concrétiser cette rencontre au sommet
qui devait se dérouler je le voulais je
le souhaitais en france et les c'est
exactement comme dans le cinéma
prenez des stars et vous ne vous
tromperez jamais parce que ça c'est
passionnant de travailler avec des stars
pour des stars aux services des stars
alors c'est ça qu'il faut célébrer c'est
ce qui m'a fait vibrer dans la boxe à
propos de parler de chevaux tout à
l'heure j'ai eu des chevaux j'ai des
champions du monde j'ai pour les
nationales je me suis arrêté après vous
débrouiller pas mal nommée très bien
mais quand même juste pour le plaisir et
qu'on regarde quand même un combat de
boxe tir et de rocco et ses frères de
visconti si vous êtes vraiment doué pour
la boxe
[Applaudissements]
au lycée comme dit
et quant à guiglo que tout est ok mais
le moyen âge un pic à des sinistres
souvent que vers l'île aux polonaises la
famille monobloc fille de 8 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on sent que ça j'étais boxeur oui mais
je voudrais déjà vous dire que vous
n'avez pas choisi le meilleur combat de
rocco et ses frères
ça c'est un combat au début du film
lorsque j'étais amateur vous arriver oui
alors qu'à la fin je veuille en
professionnel champions du oui non mais
je tenais à préciser je peux faire mieux
peut mieux faire un peu mieux peut alors
le collectionneur votre grande patience
quand même pour la date de quand on a 30
ans il ya trente ans et collectionner
quoi être non écoutez on va le faire
très vite là demain moi j'ai commencé
sur un facile et par le dessin je suis
un amoureux du dessin le dessin ancien
je fais toutes les époques à part le 18e
que je considère si vous voulez un peu
trop twitté qui correspond pas à ma
personnalité et je n'aime pas du tout
les saints 12e à part disons le les
frères tiepolo et fragonard bateau c'est
là le vrai taux met donc j'ai
collectionné le tessin depuis le 15e
siècle jusqu'à maintenant et c'est ma
passion j'ai d'ailleurs exposés les
dessins qui m'appartiennent au cours du
monde le savait et puis du dessin je
suis arrivé à la peinture et puis j'ai
connu toutes les formes évolutives de
peinture et toutes les époques de
peinture et mon oeil comme se développe
évidemment et et on avance et on
découvre les choses tout à fait nouvelle
annoncée par le dessin puis je suis
arrivé si vous voulez parler l'école de
paris je passais l'école de barbizon le
19e français de la croix jéricho miley
courbet et ses coraux puis de là je suis
arrivé aux prêts à bien les sionistes
aux impressionnistes et surtout après à
l'époque fauves qui m'a mené à
l'expressionnisme allemand est ensuite
maintenant aux cobras et puis à l'école
de paris et les années 50 et les voilà à
mon cas mal tout ça ça prend beaucoup de
temps tout ça ça prend beaucoup d'études
beaucoup de travail et surtout beaucoup
de goût mais je crois que à la base il
ya aussi si vous voulez quelque chose je
vous parle pas plus d à côté des
sculpteurs de la sculpture débrouille et
à ia si vous voulez un oeil et j'ai eu
la chance
bon j'ai pas eu grand chose dans ma vie
mais dans tous les domaines en général
on a toujours reconnu un oeil et j'ai eu
cet oeil aussi pour le dessin et pour la
peinture et je suis capable si vous
voulez tout de suite de discerner les
choses et de bien voir je ne peux pas
vous dire demain avec certitude que ce
tableau est vrai mais je peux vous dire
avec certitude que ce tableau de ce
maître et faux parce que justement je
vous ai compris pourquoi ce tales m ne
peut pas faire
telle erreur de alors à l'exposition
respectives à sion privée donc pour
actions privées au musée d'art moderne
il ya deux de vos toiles qui sont
exposés à un cubiste il ya d'abord un du
fic est admirable ça fait faux bond à
près de 2,7 après ce bon le convoi et
dites nous pourquoi vous aimez pas
féroce du bas c'était une époque tout à
fait particulière parce que tu n'es pas
au cap sounion admirable qui a duré
exactement quatre ans trois ans de 1905
à 1908 c'est le fauvisme cette espèce de
déferlement c'est une frénésie de
couleurs je veux dire quoi pour ça qu'on
a appelé le fauvisme et c'est une époque
très bref très rare par justement sa
qualité et sa rareté et le peu de temps
ça bref tu es si vous voulez brièveté
vous avez dû fille n'était pas un grand
fauve cet état il a peint je veux dire
dans le dans l'esprit du fauvisme à
l'époque c'est toi là je crois que les
1907 au havre la bête sainte-adresse le
dire très inspirés par les grands vrais
fauves qui était de la main qui était de
ringuette et matisse mais duffy n'était
pas si vous voulez a très peu pain de
toi le faut mais celle ci est l'un de
ces unes de ses plus belles est un
chef-d'oeuvre de duffy et l'autre c'est
anglaise l'eau était de la grille et sa
hache baisse de voilà qu'on peut voir
dans collard c'est ça c'est new york en
1918 c'est pourquoi vous aimez je l'aimé
comme ça parce que tu toile qui m'a je
veux dire qui m'a s'était aussi
l'évolution de mon oeil l'évolution dans
ma peinture et j'étais intéressé par les
cublize que soit anglaise qu'il soit
application à une certaine époque soit
l'âge ou amoindrir le plus difficile
dans ses passions la si vous vous
laissez pas d'être passionné passionné
c'est à la portée de tout le monde ce
qu'il faut c'est travailler pour essayer
d'avoir les moyens de travailler vous
est cultivé peut aménager fais ce métier
mes premiers deniers j'achetais des
dessins et des dessins anciens et je les
ai toujours acheter avec le coeur est
toujours acheter avec le sentiment et je
n'ai jamais acheté je veux dire dans un
but d'investissement de
même si vous vous demandez pour pouvoir
acheter non ça c'est le propre du vrai
collectionneur le vrai collectionneur au
vent je veux dire pour pouvoir acheter
mieux les meilleurs voilà et c'est
souvent très difficile de se séparer
d'objets même au bénéfice d'autres à
l'avenir
alors on passe aux airs comme un
revolver pour rigoler et non je rigole
pas ça a été quand même souvent votre
outil de travail au cinéma quand même
pas d'accord ben oui à au cinéma oui
précisé cinéma ça a été à beynost bougez
vous n'avez pas un calibre sinon la
voyez un outil de travail je veux dire
c'était une époque de 2,2 de film noir
de ce qu'on appelait le polar est bon et
qu'on était bandits ou voleur qu'on
était flic ou voyou
évidemment vous avez un stylo bernard
pivot moi jamais à revolver bon ben ça
c'est inévitable bien sûr alors c'est
vrai que j'ai fait ce que vous avez pas
marre reprochés l'armée est ce que vous
n'avez pas trop fait un des polars quand
même de les 15 dernières années la d
autant tosetti nature tantôt vous étiez
en mains privées d'auto était un flic
grèce avait pas trop fait est-ce qu'on a
précisé l'abbé nom précis non j'en ai
pas trop fin pour contraindre autres et
on s'est tous les films de dire en
général qui m'ont permis de financer de
fabriquer les autres je veux dire et je
veux dire j'étais si vous voulez je
répondais quelque part toujours à une
demande
je dis pas mon public mais d'un public
qui souhaitait ce genre je veux dire les
dernier polar que j'ai fait que je sois
parole de flic ou pour la peau d'un flic
ou ne réveillez pas un flic qui dort
j'avais une on embarque sinon ça c'était
tout à fait particulière et je suis le
mot flicky on mettait deux jours parce
que ça plaisait parce que ça marchait
vous mettez le mot flics dans dans un
film je ne pense pas en avoir trop fait
parce qu'ils étaient d'abord par mauvais
et ensuite c'est elle s'était c'était la
demande d'un certain public ce qui me
permettait de faire les autres films à
côté regarder ma filmographie vous
verrez un flic à machin a cure et un
truc écrivain auteur
bon alors tu es comme théâtre vous avez
joué deux fois auteur de les jouer deux
fois la deuxième fois donc c'était dans
les yeux crevés de gens qu en 1968
et puis la première fois en 1960 en 1960
et elvire popesco mise en scène par
visconti dommage qu'elle souhaite une
[__] de john ford théâtre élisabéthain
avec tout ce que le théâtre français
comptait de plus brillant de valentine
est ici à daniel sorano a été un saint
lucien barou et on voit une scène avec
comme l'isère et vous c'est pas vrai
quelle surprise alors là vous vous
battez regard de la mort et une fureur
révolte est il au milieu
je vois que tu peut plaire je pleure en
effet sont des larmes de deuil
je vais sur ta tôt
ce sont les mêmes qui ruisselait sur mon
visage je t'aimais
l'amour
nous sommes à bella
je me mets aussi interdire l'histoire
d'une atonie le rayon notre temps
oh vous esprit relais et vous toutes
choses créées témoigner faut il faut
quand même rappeler pour ceux qui ne le
savaient pas que le centre de l'intrigué
l'histoire était quand même son amour
incestueux un frère aimé césaire ces
voix là et à trévise est oui alors bon
alors moi j'ai eu la chance si vous
voulez j'ai eu la chance de très tôt de
travailler avec siaved mieux bon puisque
visconti au théâtre avec le théâtre
français romy qui est une grande famille
de théâtre son père était un acte au
théâtre savent sa grand mère étaient
ôtés à bourrou theater de vienne c'est
el amari la mary bale de vienne
et puis en 1968 cette pièce de jean cau
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir pour
partenaire
maribel c'était bon exceptionnelle mise
en scène par raymond rouleau qui était
ce qui est des plus grands et après j'ai
un petit peu abandonné délaissé le
théâtre parce que j'avais fait quelque
part toutes les expériences théâtrales
j'avais travaillé ce qui est le plus
grand de mieux d'exceptionnel et on me
demandait toujours mais alors le théâtre
le théâtre jeudi le théâtre ce n'est pas
ma vocation ce n'est pas ma formation
j'ai déjà connu
c'est formidable si un jour je trouve
quelque chose qui me plaît qui m'excite
qui me transférer
je le ferai et c'est arrivé 28 ans plus
tard donc vous en ces temps on va vous
voir mariniers avec francis huster dans
une pièce d'éric emmanuel je vois qu'ils
s'appellent variations énigmatiques ça
ça va être formidable événement va
rentrer francis huster
c'est un comédien et vous vous êtes un
acteur voile réponses que vous avez des
militaires c'est un comédien et un sacré
affrontements absolument ces deux écoles
tout à fait différente ce qui ne la main
n'empêche pas l'autre n'oubliez pas que
à l'origine est à ses débuts
jean jean paul belmondo est un comédien
de formation deux comédiens du
conservatoire et pouvant donc c'est la
rencontre de deux écoles c'est la
rencontre de deux styles c'est vrai sur
une c'est sur une scène fabuleuse et
dans une pièce moderne tout à fait
nouvelles écrites dit eric emmanuel
schmitt en pensant à moins et donc c'est
tout ce qui me satisfait tout ce qui me
plaisait tout ce qui m'excite ce qui me
donne envie de le faire
hervé comme voyous précisé là aussi je
vois pas mais parce que j'ai fait cette
émission comme ça des gens qui est comme
ça qu justement déjà de vous m qui vous
aiment bien qu'ils aiment beaucoup me
disais mais fond tu vois
delon c'est resté ils disaient
s'attendre et c'est resté un voyou il a
commencé bon qui voyous quand ils
étaient jeunes etc puis a fait des
grands films et puis souvent d'ailleurs
il a joué des acteurs doivent des rôles
un peu de marginaux tueur de voyous etc
et aujourd'hui c'est devenu
effectivement un homme riche et denis un
homme très cultivé qui fait beaucoup de
choses mais au fond dans sa manière
d'être
ça reste quand même un voyou qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
je pense que c'est une façon de voir les
choses
ça peut être une façon de voir les
choses c'est la vôtre et qui peut aussi
rejoindre la même moi je ne sais pas si
je suis envoyé aussi je suis resté un
loyer ce que je sais c'est que aussi
surprenant que cela puisse paraître ce
que je suis aujourd'hui c'est ce que
j'ai toujours été toute ma vie a été une
suite et une séquence d'événements plus
inattendus les uns que les autres je
suis devenu acteur par accident tout ce
que j'ai fait je les fais comme ça par
hasard ou par chance ou par accident et
je crois que ce que je suis est ce que
j'ai su rester c'est ce que j'étais dans
la petite enfance qui m'a terriblement
marqué et je ne changerai jamais alors
que où ça ça s'appelle voyous que ça
s'appelle ce que vous voulez je ne le
renie pas je ne le nie pas et je suis
très bien comme je suis parce que je
suis vraiment moi à une dépêche de l afp
est tombée aujourd'hui dix ans alain
delon a rencontré jeudi le roi de la
cavale françois bès aux palois de maison
d'arrêt de gradignan près de bordeaux
at-on appris de source pénitentiaire
ça c'était hier vous voyez que j'ai une
vie très mouvementée
je vous répondrai simplement que ça fait
partie de mes spontanéité personnel ou
de mes pulsions personnel que c'est une
visite qui ne concerne que moi et la
personne concernée que je n'ai pas envie
de m'étendre d'y répondre en place
publique on donne des exemples dit que
bon enfant
il ya une petite fille de 4 mois parce
que la mer est aussi en prison non oui
la mer est effectivement temps cherché
famille d'accueil et peut-être
serez-vous cette famille d'accueil
moi j'essaie d'aider
je peux le faire mais vous voyez que là
par exemple vous êtes aussi en
contradiction avec ce que vous pensiez
que j'étais véritablement égaux là c'est
vraiment pas le culte de moi c'est l'une
de l'autre et finalement bien alors ggc
de bernard blier dit de vous j'aime bien
l'un parce qu'il a de l'equilibre une
scène insolence tranquille le respect
dire archi professionnels le mépris le
mépris les autorités usure et le goût de
la vie violente brève et intense
c'est tout à fait celui moins bon et
alors ça c'était pascal jardin dans la
guerre à 9 ans qui faisait un portrait
de vous et allez disposer d'assez de sa
richesse vient du fait qu'il est
multiple que tous les personnages qui
cohabitent en lui sans tant de mal entre
doudot des abrupte sanglant des passages
imprévisible de la colère à la tendresse
vous avez tout compris
ben oui mais c'est pas moi c'est il
avait compris les compris là j'espère
que les téléspecteurs comprend aussi la
personne à shakespearien égaré dans une
époque de série noire il promène sur le
monde un regard d'acier ou semble
briller des larmes venue de la petite
enfance à savoir correspond à ce que je
voudrais vous disais précédemment
tout ça vient de la petite enfance et je
suis ce que j'étais dans la petite
enfance et je le resterai jusqu'à la fin
v comme vérité il a dit toute la vérité
je dis toujours la vérité j'ai appris
pas grand chose à l'école mais une des
premières choses qu'on m'a appris c'est
que là le chemin plus court chemin d'un
point l'autre était la ligne droite et
toute ma vie j'ai pris les lignes
droites
ça fait pas toujours plaisir exactement
et je prends la ligne droite bon alors z
c'est le dernier z comme zorro race un
vrai film populaire c'est à zorro c'est
particulier au site un film populaire si
j'ai fait quand mon fils avait 9 ans
vous savez que peut on a toujours été je
veux dire on a toujours été pour sont
ses enfants pour son fils un certain
moment de sa vie zorro robin des bois le
plus beau le plus grand le plus fort et
j'ai voulu à cette époque là pour mon
fils faire ce film pour qu'il soit
quelque part comme ça naïvement bêtement
gentiment le fils de zorro et j'ai fait
ce film pour monfils il avait 9 ans et
et à l'école pendant quelques temps il a
été le fils de zorro votre autre fils
qui s'appelle joie la fabia l'un fabien
les euros je fais une parenthèse je
rajoute à z je dirais ça si c'est une
chanteuse d'aujourd'hui tout à fait
moderne où il affectionne
particulièrement et que j'aime beaucoup
qui a beaucoup beaucoup de talent elle
s'appelle asine pas confondre avec zazie
l'autre qui prenait le métro ça c'est
une chanteuse
voilà alors on va terminer est ce que
oui il n'y a pas de mot j'aurais oublié
ben il y en a beaucoup le sujet d'une
autre et luciano je vous en grès par
contre je vous sais gré de ne pas voir
de ne pas m'avoir parlé de la mort
triste triste de du président françois
mitterrand de ne pas avoir parlé du
divorce de lady di et de chats non mais
vous auriez pu non non non ligue sida
dont un a tout dit le lien est trop
étonné qu est-ce que notre fin
d'émission votre mot préfacé fini à mu
bah oui j'ai moi même je suis je prends
du retard mais c'est la santé faudra
faire et de santé une led par émission à
je vous jure on l'a remplie dans ce sens
à votre mot préféré alain delon honneur
le mot vous détestez virtuel votre
drogue favorite
l'amour le son le bruit que vous aimez
le bruit du loup le hurlement du loup la
nuit dans la forêt ah bon c'est alors le
son le bruit que vous détestez le bruit
des fusils qui tirent les loups et tous
les autres animaux votre juron gros mots
blast un favori ah ça vous allez
chercher
[__] de merde [__] de merde c'est
bien français et ben voilà c'est très
bien mais je suis bien france et croyez
moi
homme ou femme pour illustrer un nouveau
billet de banque 1 je dirais
charles de gaulle ou brigitte bardot et
pourquoi pas les deux ensemble bien
sincèrement le métier vous n'auriez pas
aimé faire maître nageur il a dit si
j'ai horreur de nous et puis je me
serais très vite en lui et j'aurai pas
la patience la plante la roue l'animal
dans lequel vous aimeriez être rijkaard
alors tout de suite un malinois c'est un
berger belge suis dans mon enfance une
mali nous voilà et si dieu existe qu
aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire avoue alain delon
alors je vais vous le dire puisque tel
est ton plus grand étant plus profonds
regrets je le sais viens je te mène à
ton père et ta mère afin que pour la
première fois
enfin tu les vois ensemble mouvant
superbe émouvant merci alors j'ai pas le
temps de vous montrer des livres je
devais vous montrer notamment coraux
vivants l'exposition corps on vous avez
la chance de posséder des petits corps
au très beau c'est sa vuvuzela voir donc
c'est vous campez lève je vous irez voir
je peux pas montré il ya plein de coraux
mais on appris du juge les plus le temps
de m'en débarrasser
je veux montrer simplement le robert
craven le tour du monde du cinéma
français s'ils font le cinéma français
et étrangers aux éditions dixit et puis
quand même le manteau nyoni de aldo
tassone aux éditions flammarion
et puis ça je vous le donne et crise et
gros changement groucho marx n'a pas
fait rire taloche de l'assuré personne
ne veut jouer mais c'est idiot
vous n'avez pas d'humour n'est pas
d'humour écouter et à regarder quelles
sont les réalités sont les vôtres sont
les vôtres en beauté évidemment ils ont
un
mais non il y avait des choses
formidables mais bon merci maman merci
pour vos juillet les pensées par ce
moteur pensées et voilà
et puis les masters et voilà et rocco et
ses frères voilà de lui ou kg visconti
on peut trouver ça chez rcb c'est que je
faisais par la fnac
voilà apprenez et ça vous avez la
version française et l'aviation
italienne
erika sein de vastes un film que j'aime
beaucoup et boursin vous en dire le
moins injuste votre avis latulippe noir
voilà un magnifique magnifique voilà bon
bon revenons pas les autres bon alors et
puisque je termine en disant aux puces
c'était la 200e émission de culture je
voudrais évidemment remercier tous mes
collaborateurs qui travaillent que moi
depuis le début et notamment en plus de
michel hermant qui a réalisé cette
émission
les deux autres réalisateurs elisabeth
prêchait et alexandre tartas et puis
merci à tous les techniciens du plateau
du studio pire des gros et puis alors
une gratitude particulière pour celles
qui est mon assistante depuis 25 ans il
ya 25 ans il ya huit jours 25 ans et
donc ces jours derniers c'est pas mal
c'est la précieuse irremplaçable et très
sainte anne marie bourgnon je suis sûr
qu'elle est déjà en train de ronger
parce qu'elle est d'abord pendant la
filmer à son insu voilà et puis alors un
merci spécial à la fnac qui est mon
partenaire fidèle et valorisant depuis
le début de bouillon de culture un
cessna s'est jamais démenti depuis le
premier numéro depuis donc la fnac qui
est représentée ici ce soit par jean
paul girod qui est le directeur général
et par jacques margules est ce qui est
le directeur de la communication
mes excuses à claude sérillon pour avoir
mieux prendre un peu de retard pour
songer aux polices consacré à l'espagne
avec des élections en espagne mais
c'était quand même la 200e et puis alors
donc à partir du 28 mars jusqu'au 28
avril 52 films d'alain delon la
cinémathèque française
et puis donc quand je termine cette 200e
émission en vous remerciant alain delon
merci beaucoup et moi gérons semaine
prochaine
[Musique]